so continuing on with where we were in
the last video we're looking for this
unit tangent vector function given the
parameterization so the specific example
that i have is a function that
parameterizes a circle with radius
capital r
but i also kind of want to show in
parallel what this looks like more
abstractly so here i'll just kind of
write down in the abstract half what we
did here what we did for the unit
tangent vector
so we actually have the same thing over
here where the unit tangent vector
should be
the
should be the derivative function which
we know gives a tangent right it's just
it might not be unit but then we
normalize it we take the magnitude of
that tangent vector function
and in our specific case with the circle
once we did this and we kind of took the
x component squared y component squared
and simplified it all out we got the
function r
but in the general case we not might not
be so lucky because the magnitude of
this derivative
is going to be the square root
of x prime
of t squared right it's this the x
component of the derivative
plus y prime of t squared
just taking the magnitude of a vector
here
so when we take the entire function and
divide it by that what we get doesn't
simplify as it did in the case of a
circle
instead we have that x prime of t which
is the x component of our s prime of t
and we have to divide it by that entire
magnitude which was this whole
expression right you have to divide it
by that whole square root expression i'm
just going to kind of write dot dot dot
with the understanding that this square
root expression is what goes up there
and similarly over here we'd have y
prime of t
divided by that entire expression again
right so simplification doesn't always
happen that was just kind of a lucky
lucky happenstance of our circle example
and then now what we want
once we have the
unit tangent vector as a function of
that same parameter what we're hoping to
find is the derivative of that unit
tangent vector with respect to arc
length the arc length s and to find its
magnitude
that's going to be what curvature is but
the way to do this
is to take the derivative
with respect to the parameter t so d big
t d little t
and then divided out by
the derivative of our function s
with respect to t
which we already found and the reason
i'm doing this you know loosely if
you're just thinking of the notation you
might say oh you can kind of cancel out
the dts from each one but another way to
think about this is to say when we have
our tangent vector function as a
function of t the parameter t
we're not sure of what its changes with
respect to s right that's something we
don't know directly but we do directly
know it's changed with respect to a tiny
change in that parameter so then if we
just kind of correct that by saying hey
how much does the length of the curve
change how far do you move along the
curve as you change that parameter and
maybe if i i go back up to the picture
here
this ds dt is saying for a tiny nudge in
time
right what is the ratio of the size of
the movement there with respect to that
tiny time so the reason that this comes
out to be a very large vector right it's
not a tiny thing is because you're
taking the ratio maybe this this tiny
change was it just itty-bitty smidgen
vector but you're dividing it by like 1
1 millionth or whatever the the size of
dt that you're thinking and in this
specific case for our circle we saw that
the magnitude of this guy you know if we
took the magnitude of that guy it's
going to be equal to r which is a little
bit poetic right that the the magnitude
of the derivative is the same as the
distance from the center
and what this means in our specific case
if we want to apply this to our circle
example we take dt d big t the the
tangent vector function and i'll go
ahead and write it here we have the
derivative of our tangent vector with
respect to the parameter
and we go up and we look here we say
okay the unit tangent vector
has the formula negative sine of t and
cosine of t so the derivative of
negative sine of t is negative cosine
so over here this guy should look like
negative cosine
of t
and
the other component the y component the
derivative of cosine t as we're
differentiating our unit tangent vector
function is negative sine
negative sine of t
and what this implies is that the
magnitude of that derivative of the
tangent vector with respect to t
well what's the magnitude of this vector
you've got a cosine you've got a sine
there's nothing else in there you're
going to end up with cosine squared plus
sine squared so this magnitude just
equals one
and when we do what we're supposed to
over here and divide it by the magnitude
of the derivative right we
take this and we divide it by the
magnitude
of the derivative
the s
dt well we've already computed the
magnitude of the derivative
that was r that's what that's
how we got this r is we took the
derivative here and took its magnitude
and found it
so we find that in the specific case of
the circle the curvature function that
we want is just constantly equal to one
over r
which is good and hopeful right because
i said in the original video on
curvature that um
it's defined as one divided by the
radius of the circle that hugs your
curve most closely and if your curve is
actually a circle it's literally a
circle then the circle that hugs it most
closely is itself right so i should hope
that its curvature ends up being 1
divided by r
and in the more general case
if we take a look at what this ought to
be you can maybe imagine just how
horrifying it's going to be to compute
this right we've got our tangent vector
function which itself i
you know it's almost too long for me to
write down i just put these dot dot dots
where you're filling in x prime of t
squared plus y prime of t squared and
you're going to have to take this take
its derivative with respect to t right
it's not going to get any simpler when
you take its derivative take the
magnitude of that and divide all of that
by the magnitude of the derivative of
your original function
and i think what i'll do i'm not going
to go through all of that here it's a
little bit much and i'm not sure how
helpful it is to walk through all those
steps
but for the sake of having it for anyone
who's curious i think i'll put that into
an article and you can kind of go
through the steps at your own pace and
see what the formula comes out to be and
i'll just tell you right now maybe kind
of a spoiler alert what that formula
comes out to be
is x prime the derivative of that first
component
multiplied by y double prime the second
derivative of that second component
minus y prime first derivative of that
second component
multiplied by x double prime
and all of that
is divided by
the
uh
kind of magnitude component the x prime
squared plus y prime squared
that whole thing to the three halves
and you can maybe see why you're going
to get terms like this right because
when you're taking
when you're taking the derivative of of
when you're taking the derivative of the
unit tangent vector function you have
the square root term in it the square
root that has x primes and y primes so
that's where you're going to get your x
double prime y double prime as if the
chain rule takes you down there and you
can maybe see why this this whole x
prime squared y prime squared term is
going to maintain itself and it turns
out it comes in here at a at a three
halves power and what i'm going to do in
the next video
i'm going to go ahead and describe kind
of an intuition for why this formula
isn't random why if you break down what
this is saying it really does give
a feeling for the curvature the you know
amount that a curve curves that we want
to try to measure so it's almost like
this is a third way of thinking about it
right the first one i said you have
whatever circle most closely hugs your
curve and you take one divided by its
radius
and then the second way you're thinking
of this dtds the
change in the unit tangent vector with
respect to arc length and taking its
magnitude and of course all of these are
the same but they're just kind of three
different ways to think about it or
things that you might plug in when you
come across a function and i'll go
through an example i'll go through
something where we're really computing
the curvature of something that's not
not just a circle
um
but with that i'll see you next video